quick revision and review right what
have we been doing I'm just a lost two
or three lessons what kinds of I'm using
math so we've been looking at
percentages good what do we look at
before percentages to decimals decimals
what to be looking for for decimals very
very similar these guys write fractions
good okay we'll stop there you could
connect them on others but now here's
the idea that I want to get into your
head okay all four of these all four of
these are the same idea just kind of
wearing different clothes if you like
okay how they all related to each other
yeah all about
I need another color another color no no
no I haven't read somewhere here we go
that's true but these are really really
related everything is related just like
you know if we go back like you know 50
generations you're probably all related
but these guys are like cousins yeah we
have all about comparing things okay
it's where for instance you do remember
I said oh are the percentages what if
I've got 30 girls in 30 boys I'd say
that's 50% 50% which lets me compare
these two sir
that's what said it just decimals are
the same fractions are just another way
to say it so we've gone through
fractions decimals percentages now I get
a little ratios and it's the last idea
that has to do with comparing quantities
okay I should put that down as well so
should you
it's about comparing quantities it's
what you've got stuff
items that are similar and you want to
compare them with each other now because
these are all the same ID they share a
lot of things in common okay so for
instance in a fraction he's an example
there are two numbers right
we give them names by the way new right
up to them in right in exactly the same
way in a ratio you've got two numbers
right I already call them but your
numerator the denominator we think just
call them the first one and say come up
they do actually have special names well
it's called like the antecedent and
something else but it doesn't matter you
don't need to know what the name is but
the point is that there are two numbers
in the same way just like there's three
numbers there right if you want to put a
ratio in simplest form it's exactly the
same as putting a fraction in simplest
form okay so for instance 3 over 6 3
over 6 right we know how to simplify
this fraction we divide both numbers by
3 and that's how you get a heart well
all of these ratios are the same but
this is in simplest form of this is not
okay that makes sense now also just like
fractions right the order of these
numbers matches the order matters so for
instance one to two is not the same is
not the same as two to one right in just
the same way that if I turn this
fraction upside down
they not say 1/2 is not equal to 2
everyone just like 1 to 2 isn't the same
as 2 to 1 these are the same and these
are the same but they're not the same as
each other the order matters okay and
just to draw one more parallel for you
right
aha is kind of like writing um well it's
not kind of like writing it's the same
as writing 1/2 right and division
division you the order matters right 2
divided by 1 and 1/2 are the same thing
so I keep on saying I'm trying to make
them you know clear your mind
infractions are very very similar
together because a lot of things you do
to fractions like simplifying or like
thinking about the order they're exactly
the same for ratios okay